you know the other thing the impression
I get with you is too that like even
though you spent years doing stand-up
comedy and you know all these guys
you're not that emotionally attached to
stand up comedy like when I talk to
Seinfeld this guy he loves it he lives
it he loves to break down a joke and
analyze it and it's really fascinating I
enjoy being around him I've gotten to
know him somewhat and he he really he's
also the BET like now you're talking
about the kind of Craftsman like he's
the guy that you would go to like in an
old Italian Village where like there's
this one guy right and he does these
like who else is like that Leno is she
because you know I don't know Jay at all
because it's you know he was always in
Los Angeles and he was up before and
I've gotten to know Jerry just a little
bit more
from being here but your comedy friends
it's interesting you know you go out
after shows and stuff but I was never a
hangout guy right like I didn't so there
wasn't a lot of he was much more of a
hangout guy like they all used to get
together for brunch and right and they'd
go to a game you don't do that no I'm
kind of a hermit like it's but isn't
there a certain necessity to hanging out
because then you kind of learn what when
you're in the clubs so that was during
my club years yeah I was always at the
club hanging out hanging out who told
you you could be funny and make a living
on it my friends they did they didn't
tell me I could make a living but they
my friends were the ones that I
entertained how old are you when you go
to do stand-up the first time that was
probably 23 or 24. oh I had lived when I
got out of school I went to back home to
Trenton lived with a couple of my
buddies and worked in a bar bartending I
would bartending yeah
um it was called the bottom half it was
underneath a liquor store
but I also got a job at this club called
City Gardens which was a punk Club on
Calhoun Street in Trenton and it was uh
a dangerous violent place and I've never
been happier and it was there that I
started to see
creative people people that weren't
because I I were you good the first time
you went up no horrible horrible so bad
Bitter End on Bleaker Street no one
would have bet on your heart I would try
different personas different things oh
yeah like what are some of your personas
or what were you Seinfeld was such a
influence and sort of you'd kind of grab
that Rhythm a little bit right oh what
are you gonna
nothing
um just [__] awful terrible terrible
terrible how many years does it take
before you get good like where you'd say
you know people said hey that guy's
pretty funny that's hard because you can
get people to say that without being
good but when did you start feeling good
here's what I feel good about if you ask
me like what's my best
what made me feel the best about Show
Business and I honest to God it's that I
did it it's that I moved it's that I
mustered up enough energy
to pack all my [__] into a U-Haul with
no job and drove to New York I had a
six-week sublet
and I did it in other words the climb
the fact that you were successful and
you worked at it and you constantly kept
going and pushing yourself it's not a
joy necessarily but it's at least no but
I can remember some nights so what
happened was that the cellar I was
working at this place called panchito's
on McDougall
um doing the day bartending in a Mexican
restaurant which like truly the worst
job all you do all day is cut limes and
make margarita mix for the night guy
who's gonna clean the [__] up and you're
gonna walk out with a two dollar tip out
so but then at night I would go to the
Comedy Cellar and back then it wasn't
what it is today yeah it was still a
basement in the village but the show
would start at eight and it would just
roll all night there was no different
settings and it was never packed except
on the weekends and uh Manny Dorman who
who ran the club and Este who books it
put me on as the last guy every night
from Sunday through Thursday is that a
bad slot two o'clock in the morning
um that's the worst slot I guess it's
the slot that they give someone that for
some reason they think let's just see
what happens to this guy right let's see
what he uses this for right and so you
develop your act
for a jaundiced weight staff and like
drunk Dutch people who wandered in and
actually thought there was going to be
music right and but tough crowd but you
learned how to be
yourself
and once you learn how to be yourself
that's when it opens up right you're so
relaxed you learn how to channel what
you actually care about it's and what
you actually think about it you're right
and you find yourself that's true in
radio and that's what it was yeah